we can speak to actually one protester
here just hi there thanks very much for
talking to us I know that you're quite
upset in the solution by boy what
happened here tell us what reporting the
real message is being lost I'm sure
happy when I hear because everyone else
is here the meaning behind all of this
while I'm here more than just don't read
particularly the black people here at
this woman and become lost and become
lost people find people doing all sorts
of thing eventually gonna tarnish while
we're here when I'm a counselor at the
bad people here the same why we're here
we're here to be bad people where to
protest has been happening for hundreds
of years
recent years sister Mike police
brutality knees knees upon it before
here but right now I'm afraid it's going
to be repaired as us the black people
being a violent people here when we
haven't come and finish early officer go
through family became of course there's
no us that's not why we're here
I mean it's I should say because earlier
today thousands and thousands of people
here making their point very peacefully
trying to get that message across it was
a great show of unity of course it was
because there's people who who were here
with that at the same mind who come in
with the same mind but unfortunately
right now I'm thinking has got to be
repeated violence and they look at us
again and the cycle continues when we
the black he were here my brothers and
sisters around me here yeah well my
problem yeah
both brothers and sisters around me we
came there for a reason and as to show
unity well that's good enough